[Applause]
Haley Baldwin and Kendall Jenner put in
the hot seat for a special Apple music
carpool karaoke episode where they turn
off Panic at the Disco to take a test
what are we doing come on we're doing a
lie-detector Jen oh we're gonna get you
hooked up thumbs up okay all right we're
ready
have you ever created a fake Instagram
to look at what your ex-boyfriend is
doing
Kendall was previously linked to ASAP
Rocky Harry Styles and NBA stars Blake
Griffin and Ben Simmons after being put
on the spot the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star didn't go easy on her
model besties asking Baldwin what her
husband Justin Bieber really thinks
about Kinney does Justin think I'm cool
[Music]
of course
that's a lie
although Kindle is long time friends
with mr. and mrs. Bieber even sharing
matching friendship tattoos with Haley
don't expect the 21 year old to make
room for any Justin inspired ink any
time soon the blonde beauty told
Harper's Bazaar quote I want more but
I'm keeping space for my kids names and
certain sentimental things and I don't
want to feel all the cute spots before I
get there are you happy her and Justin
Bieber engaged
yeah whatever makes them happy I'm happy
I've been friends with both of them for
a very long time stuff that everybody's
happy in Atlantic as for how Haley feels
since secretly tying the knot with
Justin back in September she had nothing
but praise for her man telling the mag
he is incredible he crushes everything
every song every feature it's crazy to
see what he does I'm always blown away
it's an amazing feeling for sure
[Music]